la batalla se intensifica en el donbass
donde hoy las tropas rusas habrían
tenido el control por unos momentos de
una de esas retenes que controlan esa
ruta que va de la ciudad de bach mut
hasta las poblaciones del issys sants y
se vieron done ex en la provincia de
luján que están asediadas por las
fuerzas rusas desde hace varios días
según el gobernador de la provincia
esta ruta sigue estando en control de
los ucranianos después de esta batalla y
es la única manera de acceder a sally
sin embargo el gobernador decía que las
tropas ucranianas habrían salido de
controlar algunas áreas de esa provincia
y de esas ciudades sin embargo otras
versiones que vienen desde allí desde el
campo militar dicen que los ucranianos
están reforzando esas posiciones y
todavía están luchando por controlarlas
la única realidad que sabemos es que
cada vez los heridos son más la
situación es más crítica para quienes
pelean allí se habla de que 25
batallones rusos están tratando de tener
el control de esta zona mientras que
allí hay tres brigadas
ucraniana lo que representaría alrededor
de 10.000 hombres todos los días llegan
cada vez más heridos a esa población de
bach mude a las ciudades aledañas pero
las también las armas se intensifican el
número de armamento y de logística que
llega hacia la región cómo hemos sido
testigos durante los últimos días es
cada vez mayor y las tropas ucranianas
siguen luchando a pesar de las
dificultades y de los avances de las
tropas rusas